process here because you bring out the bishop
like this uh it can become very vulnerable
right away so i'm not sure that i like
the like the variational approach here
no please don't and it's too soon it's too
soon hikaru we didn't even reach a climax
i do check is coming and what's 92 chips oh
what's going on here 92 c2 and cars oh no
we're nice to see one take out f3 take it off
three oh my god you have to take on f3 dude
bishop d3 a brilliant pre-move not a pre-move
he stopped the pre-move that is hikaru nakamura
showing off his bullet skills magazine's
down to five seconds he's gonna move quickly
gosh i've never seen magnus play a
move like that like ever oh my goodness
he was winning that game and he gives
it away gosh really my queen d6 checker
wait bishop f5 so i can tip and i fly with my
knife amazing cash oh my god five is incredible
the thing went oh my he played it oh my gosh
unbelievable that is the move of the day that is
incredible and knight h1 rook takes h1 oh my
gosh this is mate everywhere gotta made him now
don't botch the king g4 queen g3 okay okay
there's no immediate made by taking on g2
should be good enough or h5 check 92 92 take the
queen and run oh my god model attack worthy of
i know the computer says equal but i
have no idea what to play here with black
what a freaking move here comes
queen of six oh always sacks
the bishop c5 check coming is that the
idea that was set if king ji won bishop c5
and if the king runs out here comes now black
is winning oh my gosh we shake [ __ ] holy bleep
i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a draw
oh no don't play king c7 please oh
my repetition what can we see but wow
it's connor it's feeling oh my god what
how is that a draw by repetition
oh my god look who came in this room oh my
the question is does hafu take
the grand master approach here
and just take the perpetual
for the championship this is
a good old-fashioned soviet
grandmaster would just would just
doesn't matter we gotta listen and she's
about to deliver the goods i just said it
yeah i kind of like hiding on h7 and
maybe she's going to do that now yeah
that's a nice little hiding spot
and now rook v8 um and queen and me
oh my gosh that is the swindle of the century
wow i did it i did it i oh my god i said king
h7 i love this hiding spot oh my gosh what
did i do that is absolutely devastating
here comes queen e7 of course if i predicted
nope no hikara wants more i was going to say
if i predicted a decisive result we'd get
a perpetual draw curse bishop bishop oh
gladys love our champion versus someone we
think materials on because we don't think maxime
has enough to get a win here which would
force a bullet tiebreaker unfortunately
for mvl he missed his chances earlier in the
same game but i don't think they're coming back
okay bringing the king of the board this
is nice remember the id so there was a
trick there if queen f7 the move was
queen he said oh he misses kinky seven
oh he doesn't maxime tricks him oh and hike
freaks out oh my god maxime tricked him holy crap
oh my god here comes everyone yelling at dan dan
jinxed it it's not my fault he blundered the queen
ending i'm just one man oh my freaking god no
resignation for you vivid okay no resignation
coming your way why would you not do that well
because you want to waste some i think if your
air grows and you really do want to waste time off
the match clock oh my gosh stalemate that's why
you don't resign that was still me oh my gosh
rook seat in brook 64 the b5 we see the drama
is real this is that he's got 10 seconds to get
one puzzle right and he goes to the corner queen
one queen b one queen f1 queen oh no he missed
it for two seconds who takes v8 defeat broke
oh my gosh the time ticks away oh look at him he
goes nuts and hans neiman is going nuts that was
crazy that was absolutely bonkers i cannot
believe that just happened that was crazy
oh my gosh there's mate open knight b4
this is amazing oh my gosh united 192 mate
knight f192 mate oh my god oh this is
incredible how oh my that ness was that
exclamation mark on top i'm pulling up that board
that is what is that that was sick i know it's bad
what what what did hikaru say about this move you
say he would not be happy yeah what is danny doing
danny what are you doing danny i mean i know
danny is bad but danny what are you doing
this is why people want no chat no chat no chat no
chat hans is a good player danny is bad no no chad
no chat chad don't make jokes about then
know that no no chad please stop chat no
okay chad i get it i get it what's
happening somebody help me out the
queen is coming to g4 but is there a
mate there's no meat there's bishops
oh my gosh what's happening queen
h2 and they take on f4 we check
or this oh my gosh we might just see a repetition
what in the world have we seen here now
what is working shoot she may forget she wants
you blundered oh my gosh she remember gets one
check and even that didn't work because the queen
would have taken but it looks like all is said and
done crazy game and what a crazy match this is
a very sad story for executives oh no oh my god
there's no way and and tactics that occur
in the middle game but this is kind of on
cue because normally the tactics you get
you should also be familiar with if you're
getting pawn structures you know clearly
nepal was not familiar with this opening
and i want to say i called it robert i said
what did i say team india needed to turn it
around they needed to be led by their co-captain
co-board and he's about to deliver mate and four
what in the world i mean i'm looking at this and
i'm speechless for pretty much the first time ever
queen h6 is the threat with queen g7 mate to
follow and there's no way to stop it well you
could play king of cheat right but then the
problem is after queen h6 rook g8 stopping me
on g7 it can't stop made on h7 after that so this
is a forced checkmate and vichy i mean putting in
the the psychological work of what might yon the
punjabi not be comfortable with today and he gets
the victory that quickly you do not see that kind
of miniature against yonder palmer she pretty much
bye